[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will discuss and
speculate about the biological origins
of the most diverse Titans more
specifically from which species or class
of animals that these titles originate
from which as the most of us suggests
were irradiated by the environment
during the ancient times so which life
forms did they mutate or evolve from
let's get into it
firstly let's start with the skull
crawlers which as stated by the movie
novelization of Godzilla vs Kong evolved
from non-amient basal reptilimovs so in
the Permian period these amphibian
tetrapods started to evolve towards a
reptilian line some were elongated
ill-like with diminutive Limbs and it is
believed that the skull crawlers were
descendants of such highly irradiated
specimens of such a class of animals
number two in the case of Kong he is a
member of a Simeon super species or Apes
that originated in the hollow Earth a
rich habitat of giant animals under the
Earth's surface while the species has a
common ancestor with modern day Apes
they are thought to be a whole different
classification of Life probably
branching out from a previous ancestor
thirdly Rodan species heavily resemble
sterosols though it doesn't seem to be
directly related to them due to its
fiery nature nevertheless it is still
presumed to have evolved from an unknown
basal pterodactyl species from the
Mesozoic Era since flying reptiles did
not evolve until the Jurassic period yet
it also has bird-like qualities which
further proves its arcosaurian Origins
number 4 Mothra with its various life
stages and appearance which is identical
to that of a mouth is as such presumed
to be a super species evolved from these
little critters but then Mothra if she
was an Asian life form would no doubt be
traced back to the Permian leptidopteran
species of giant moths such things have
been extinct since the Permian Triassic
Extinction event
number 5 muros on the other hand these
murals must have definitely evolved from
the Permian paramega sarcopteran life
forms which are beaked insects insects
with beaks these insects evolve the
ability to fold their wings as well over
their body much like the male Muto and
their life cycle include nymphs which
has a very weird appearance strangely
they died out in the permanent period
and no other beaked insects have ever
been found so by inference mutos would
have been from this para Mega sock-up
Terence
number six Godzilla he here is not an
ancient dinosaur unlike some of touhou's
origin stories because dinos evolved 100
million years after him speculations
have it that he may have evolved from
either an absence or diabsids from the
Permian age which are early forms of
reptiles and may have retained
amphibious traits like gills organs
which Godzilla also possesses here in
the master verse
number seven the Behemoth The hulking
Mammoth sloth died in was probably
needed a sloth or a mammoth in origin
looks can be deceiving and biologists
always scope for skeletal features to
identify a class of animals the Behemoth
might have evolved from calcotheriums
based on its skeletal structure and long
for limbs with powerful Knuckles and
Claws to walk on which calicothereums do
have the Tusk on the other hand would
only be mutated traits due to
irradiation
number eight wombats are seen as giant
snakes with membranous wings it's not
that difficult to ascertain their
Origins they would have evolved from
venomous snakes that ventured too far
and were flung into the hollow Earth as
the only snakes with enlarged ribs near
the skull were Cobras the war bats would
have probably been a descendant of an
ancient race of cobras as the earliest
Cobra evolved 23 million years ago so
it's both highly speculative and also
very probable
number nine Cilla although stated to
possess the internal biology of a squid
might have not been an evolved super
species of such judging by the ability
to grow a hard shell exterior and limbs
it might have evolved from a Squid's
close and ancient cousin the Nautilus
which would explain the internal
biological similarities as both were
cephalopods
number 10 nakika is closely related to
Cilla as another evolved cephalopod
Titan but it is not a squid nor a super
species of Nautilus its big and bulbous
head and highly flexible set of eight
tentacle limbs would suggest that it
might have evolved from a lineage of
cephalopods that include the octopus
like the octopus the Titan also has
certain sex or gender bending abilities
number 11 camazod stated as a bad Titan
is pretty obvious as in the case of gong
these are both mammalian species Super
species this Titan would have evolved
pretty late in the grand scheme of
things just like gong probably in a
cenozoic era from ancient bat species
that ventured into the hollow Earth and
got irradiated by the power cells and
got huge in size
number 12 the genital species and its
Alpha subtitin greatly resemble the
ancient armored Dunkleosteus and
obviously would have evolved from it or
a closely related fish species it has
massive bony teeth-like plates jutting
outwards from its jaw and its pectoral
fins are covered in spikes and end in
three claw-like digits including an
opposable thumb
number 13 the shinamura this is a swamp
species that acts as a large colony and
the individual notes are ancient
parasitic Colony cells shinamura's
gigantic super Colony cells are black in
color also blue in some cases and
resembles starfish in looks although it
might just be an appearance thing as the
starfish a member of the Primitive
echinoderms have no such history as
being either parasites or swarm species
number 14 The Hollow Earth lizards are
an offshoot of the Gojira species with
the lizard's Jagged dorsal plates and
general appearance being indicators of
this relation which means that they also
evolve from either an absids or the
absids wherever Godzilla came from they
also came from there their squatting
limbs also provides proof that they are
not of the same Branch as the dinosaurs
which have an evolved perfect girdle
that allowed for legs to be parallel to
the spine in posture and 15 the Maya
squid this isn't really a full-fledged
Titan and could be termed as a subtitle
like the janitor the Maya squid is
classified as a megalaport within the
architis subdivision of giant squids
according to Monarch's super species
profile although the my squid was
initially thought to be a distant
relative of the Great Pacific octopus
with some remarkable evolutionary
alterations
as for Tiamat and Methuselah there are
no substantial links with ancient
animals both are very unique and they
are definitely reptiles but it is
difficult to ascertain their positions
in the branches of the tree of life so I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam